so it's uh
it's really interesting how these little
battles can steer the directions of war
of course
me growing up in the soviet union we
didn't hear much about this battle
uh just like you said millions of
soviets died all those
people in history that you read about
dying those are all civilians but i mean
not all but a very large number of them
are civilians
and their stories obviously that's the
rooted
the literature the poetry the music just
the way people talk the way they drink
vodka the way they love
the way they hate the way they fear
that's all like rooted in world war
ii and world war one and so
but we never kind of think about
europe and we certainly grown up
didn't think about their role in the
united states all this there's plenty of
stories of heroism in uh
in the soviet union enough enough for
many lifetimes so
but it was fascinating to read from a
greek perspective
um because i you know i don't have many
greek friends
i'm hoping to change that uh
this is the beginning of a love affair
of your people
uh yeah likewise the americans don't
hear about the
soviet contribution to the end of world
war ii because obviously we became
you know enemies after that because of
the two systems but
yeah without the russians with world war
ii wouldn't have been one either
you